KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE WITH
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
A BIG MEETING TODAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND LEADERS OF
CONGRESS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GOT TO
WITNESS THIS ONE, AND IT WAS
PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY.
THE PRESIDENT ALLOWED CAMERAS TO
RULE FOR MORE THAN 45 MINUTES AS
HE AND LAWMAKERS NEGOTIATED HOW
BEST TO REACH AN IMMIGRATION
DEAL.
HE IS NOW OPEN TO AN AGREEMENT
COMING INTO PHASES.
FIRST ADDRESSING YOUNG
IMMIGRANTS AND BORDER SECURITY
WITH BROADER ISSUES TO BE
NOW WITH THE COMMITMENT THAT WE
GO IN TO A COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM PROCEDURE.
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT DICK IS
SAYING.
WE ARE GOING TO DO DACA AND THEN
WE WILL START ON PHASE TWO.
COMPREHENSIVE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO DO DACA
FIRST.
>> Kimberly: THE PRESIDENT
THINKS LEGISLATION SHOULD BE A
>> 62% OF THE TRUMP VOTERS
SUPPORT A PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP
FOR THE DACA KIDS IF YOU HAVE
STRONG BORDERS.
YOU HAVE CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE, MR. PRESIDENT, AND YOU
NEED TO CLOSE THE DEAL.
>> IF WE DO THIS PROPERLY, DACA,
YOU ARE NOT SO FAR AWAY FROM
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
AND IF YOU WANT TO TAKE IT THAT
FURTHER STEP, I WILL TAKE THE
HEAT.
I DON'T CARE.
I WILL TAKE THE HEAT.
I WILL TAKE ALL THE HEAT YOU
WANT TO GIVE ME.
>> Kimberly: THERE IS ONE
>> ANY AGREEMENT WITHOUT THE
YOU NEED IT.
YOU NEED THE WALL.
I'D LOVE NOT TO BUILD A WALL BUT
I WILL TELL YOU THE I.C.E.
OFFICERS AND BORDER PATROL
AGENCIES, THEY SAY IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THE WALL, IN CERTAIN AREAS
OBVIOUSLY THAT ARE PROTECTED BY
NATURE, IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
WALL, YOU CANNOT HAVE SECURITY.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> Kimberly: DID YOU LOVE IT?
THE WALL.
BEING IN D.C., A LOT A MEETINGS
ARE LIKE THAT BEHIND THE SCENES
AND THEN AFTERWARDS BOTH SIDES
GO TO THEIR OWN CAMERAS AND
MICROPHONES WILL THEY TAKE TURNS
AND THEY ARE MUCH MORE PARTISAN
AND AIRPLANE TO THEIR BASE.
WHAT THIS DID WAS IT WAS LIKE
WATCHING A CITY COUNCIL MEETING
ON LOCAL ACCESS TELEVISION BUT
YOU ARE ACTUALLY IN THE CABINET
ROOM WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
ABIDE -- AND BIPARTISAN
LAWMAKERS WHO DIDN'T KNOW THIS
AS EVERYONE WAS THERE A NEW -- I
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE TALKING
A CLEAN DACA BILL AND THE
PRESIDENT SAID THAT'S GREAT AND
McCARTHY SAID THAT WOULDN'T
INCLUDE SECURITY.
IT'S A LITTLE RISKY TO BE OPENLY
NEGOTIATING LIKE THAT BUT I
THOUGHT IT WAS AMAZINGLY
REFRESHING.
AND DACA HAVE BACKED OFF.
ABOVE THE FALLS, FRONT PAGE
STORY ON "USA TODAY" INCLUDED
THREE QUOTES ON THE FRONT PAGE
FROM PRETTY HARD-LINE
IMMIGRATION GROUP SAYING IF WE
NEED TO DO AMNESTY FOR CHILDREN
WHO WERE BROUGHT HERE ILLEGALLY
AND IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT,
CONGRESS WON'T HAVE ANY PROBLEM
FROM US.
THE PRESIDENT IS REALLY AT THIS
OPPORTUNITY WHERE HE COULD DO
IS THAT YOUR VOTERS ACTUALLY
WANT YOU TO DO THIS BUT WE ARE
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE'S WILLING
WE ARE GOING TO VOTE OR
SOMETHING THAT MAKES COMMON
SENSE.
IT COMES TO IMMIGRATION BUT I
THINK IF YOU CAN GET TO A GOOD
SOLUTION, LET POLITICAL BYGONES
BE BYGONES AND GET IT DONE.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, THE WALL.
>> Jesse: LOOKED LIKE A VERY
STABLE GENIUS OUT THERE.
I LIKE BOARDROOM TRUMP ALMOST AS
MUCH AS I LIKE RALLY TRUMP.
EVERYTHING UNDER IS UNDER
CONTROL.
HE DROVE A LOT OF MOMENTUM IN
THAT MEETING.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT KIND OF
WHEELING AND DEALING AMONG BOTH
SIDES LIKE THAT EVER BEFORE.
IT WAS AN INCREDIBLE SCENE TO
WATCH.
THE CORNERSTONE OF THE DEAL IS
CHAIN MIGRATION, LOTTERY, THE
WALL, AND MERIT-BASED.
THAT'S WHAT TRUMP WANTS.
THE LEFT WANTS DACA, THE CLEAN
DACA VOTE.
TRUMP ALMOST FELL FOR IT AND
THEN GOT RESCUED.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO THE DACA
DEAL UNLESS WE GET BORDER
FROM H.R., WE DON'T CALL K.G.
I DON'T KNOW WHY AMERICA DOESN'T
LIKE THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE ARE PLAYING
CHANCE WITH THE IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
MERIT-BASED, HE SAID THAT'S WHAT
CANADA DOES.
I THOUGHT THE LIBERALS LOVE
CANADA.
WE WANT TO EMULATE THEIR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
LET'S EMULATE THEIR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SQUARELY.
IF THEY GET ANYTHING CLEAN, I
THE WALL.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO IT
ALL AT ONCE.
TRUMP SAYS HE'S READY TO TAKE
THE HEAT.
JUAN, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THIS
IN TERMS OF THE OBJECTS?
GIVING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE A
FRONT ROW SEAT TO HOW THESE
NEGOTIATIONS GO AND CALLING OUT
PEOPLE, LIKE WHAT ARE THEY
SUPPORT ABOVE.
AND PROBABLY SHOWCASING HIS
INTELLIGENCE AND DEALMAKING
SKILLS.
>> Juan: GENIUS STABILITY.
I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN EVIDENT.
I'VE WRITTEN ABOUT THIS.
IT'S PRETTY EVIDENT DONALD TRUMP
HAS OPENED THE DOOR TO A DEAL, A
CONFERENCE OF DEAL, BECAUSE HE'S
THE ONE WHO SAID MARCH IS THE
AND SAID TO THE DEMOCRATS LET'S
MAKE A DEAL.
HE'S BEEN TALKING IN HARD TERMS,
AS JESSE WAS SUGGESTING, ABOUT
THE WALL, ABOUT CHAIN MIGRATION.
AND THESE THINGS, THE WALL, IT'S
IN THE MOOD FOR IT BECAUSE THEY
THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS BUT THE
DREAMERS HAVE BEEN ATTACKING
NANCY PELOSI AS SHE WAS SPEAKING
IN SAN FRANCISCO, SAYING WE ARE
NOT A BARGAINING CHIP.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS?
THEY HELD OFF IN DECEMBER.
NOW WE HAVE IT FRONT AND CENTER.
THE KEY HERE IS THAT TRUMP WANTS
A DEAL.
HE SAYS WHAT WE HAVE IN COMMON
IS BOTH SIDES WANT A DEAL.
THE PROBLEM AND DEALING WITH
DONALD TRUMP, THE GREAT
BUSINESSMAN NEGOTIATOR, IS WHEN
YOU COME TO THE NITTY-GRITTY,
THE FINE POINTS, HE IS LACKING.
HE DOESN'T KNOW THE FINE POINTS.
NOW, THE PROBLEM GOING BACK TO
GANG OF EIGHT, IN '16 IF I'M
RIGHT.
YOU GET THE FAR RIGHT TOUGH SHOW
IF YOU WANT TO COME IN THE
COUNTRY, GET TO THE BACK OF THE
LIBRARY THESE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
THROWN OUT.
LIKE YOU ARE GOING TO THROW
12 MILLION PEOPLE OUT.
NOW THEY SAY IT'S A MATTER OF
LAW.
THEY BROKE THE LAW.
THEY ARE BAD PEOPLE.
GOING TO HAVE TO EXPERIENCE.
HE SAYS HE WILL TAKE THE HEAT
BUT EVEN FOR A STABLE GENIUS,
JESSE, IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
HEAT COMING FROM THE RIGHT.
>> Jesse: HE LOVES IT AND HE'S
DEALT WITH AT HIS WHOLE LIFE.
>> Juan: I AM ALL FOR IT
BECAUSE I THINK YOU WOULD BE
SEAN HANNITY WORLD.
>> Jesse: AND IMMIGRATION PLAN
WITH LOVE AND HE CAN GET AWAY
WITH THINGS OF BEEN LIKE THAT
BECAUSE HE TALKED ABOUT TAKING
OUT ALL THE BAD HOMBRES.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE 200,000 ALL
SALVADORANS WHO WERE HERE AS A
MATTER OF A VOUCHER, SOME KIND
OF BENEFIT BECAUSE OF THE CHAOS
IN EL SALVADOR AND THEN APPLY
THE SAME STANDARD TO THE HAITIAN
THE SAME STANDARD TO THE HAITIA,
NICARAGUANS.
HE HAS ALIENATED JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY SOUTH OF THE BORDER.
RIGHT SUPPORTERS.
>> Kimberly: LET'S NOT
ALIENATE GREG ON OUR BORDER.
>> Greg: I WAS ABOUT TO GO TO
AFTERWARDS WAS ANN COULTER'S
HE IS WORKING THE ASSUMPTION
THAT IF YOU ARE FOR TRUMP YOU
WILL ACCEPT ANY KIND OF TRUMP
THEREIN.
I HAPPEN TO BELIEVE HE'S RIGHT.
WHEN YOU SAW TODAY, AND I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN UNDERPLAY WHAT YOU
SAW TODAY.
WHAT YOU SAW TODAY WAS SOMETHING
NO PRESIDENT REALLY HAS DONE.
THIS IS THE MOST TRANSPARENT
PRESIDENCY WILL EVER SEE.
I CAN'T SAY THAT BECAUSE WE
RUNNING OUR COUNTRY BUT HE'S A
HUMAN CANNONBALL.
HE JUMPS IN, MAKES THE BIGGEST
NOISE, MAKES THE BIGGEST SPLASH.
HE FIGURES OUT WHAT EVERYONE CAN
HE FIGURES OUT THE DEAL AND
MAKES NOISE.
THIS WAS A RESPONSE TO THE BOOK,
IN MY OPINION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT
THINK ABOUT THIS COMPARISON.
THIS IS THE BIGGER STORY HERE.
THEY ARE CHASING A MENTAL HEALTH
FANTASY.
MEANWHILE TRUMP IS CHASING A
MENTAL HEALTH REALITY.
TODAY HE EXPANDED COVERAGE FOR
VETERANS FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
BECAUSE OF THE RISE IN SUICIDES.
THIS IS TO LOWER SUICIDE RATES.
WHILE THE DESPICABLE MEDIA IS
BELIEVING IN SOME DOCTOR WHO WAS
BASICALLY FALLEN OFF THE FACE
OFF THE EARTH AS A MENACE TO
SOCIETY.
HE IS OUT THERE TRY TO HELP SAVE
LIVES.
GO BACK TO THE MEETING.
EVERYBODY WHO WATCHED IT WAS
TRANSFIXED AND IT WAS PRETTY
FUNNY WATCHING OTHER NETWORKS
ADMIT, LIKE, THIS IS SOMETHING
GOOD.
AND I HAVE TO SAY I'M REALLY
WE ARE ALL DREAMERS, ALL RIGHT?
JUST BECAUSE YOUR SPECIFIC
PERSON DOESN'T MAKE YOU A
DREAMER, EVERYBODY IN THE
UNITED STATES AS A DREAMER.
SO CALLING THIS SPECIFIC GROUP
DREAMER.
THAT'S DREAMER PRIVILEGE.
>> Juan: WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
>> Greg: I UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
IS.
IT'S A WAY TO TRY TO SEPARATE IT
SO THESE PEOPLE ARE
DISADVANTAGED AND UNIQUE BUT THE
REST OF US ARE ALL BAD PEOPLE.
WE ARE ALL DREAMERS.
IT'S ABOUT EVERYBODY WHO WANTS
STRONG ENFORCEMENT OF THE BORDER
IS SOMEHOW HATEFUL AND EVIL.
>> Juan: I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> Greg: HE SPENT 4 MINUTES
SAYING THAT.
>> Juan: RUN THE TAPE.
MOST DEMOCRATS THE WALL BECAUSE
THEY SEE IT AS A REDUNDANT AND A
WASTE OF MONEY BECAUSE WE --
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT WHY THEY
OPPOSE IT.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE MONEY.
>> Greg: THERE IS NO SUCH
THING TO DEMOCRATS IS A WASTE OF
MONEY.
>> Juan: I HEAR THE RHETORIC.
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT RHETORIC.
>> Juan: WE HAVE PUT BOOTS ON
THE GROUND ON THE BORDER,
DRONES, ELECTRONIC SENSORS.
A BETTER SYSTEM.
WHAT YOU GET FOR THE PEOPLE YOU
DON'T WANT TO CALL DREAMERS, 62%
OF AMERICANS.
>> Greg: ALL OF US ARE
DREAMERS.
>> Juan: KIDS WHO CAME AS
CHILDREN.
>> Dana: THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHO GAVE THEM THE
NAME.
IT AUTOMATICALLY EVOKES SOME
GOOD WORK BUT...
>> Greg: YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
ENHANCED BORDER SECURITY AND A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP TOGETHER
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT TRUMP IS
GOING TO DO AND RIGHT NOW THEY
SHRINK WHO SAID HE WAS UNSTABLE
IS SHRINKING BECAUSE THERE ARE
PEOPLE LOOKING REALLY SMALL.